cette semaine notre coup de coeur et le
film l'odyssée réalisé par jérôme salle
avec lambert wilson
audrey tautou et pierre niney 1948
jacques yves cousteau sa femme et ses
deux fils vivent au paradis dans une
jolie maison surplombant la méditerranée
mais cousteau ne rêvent que d'aventurés
grâce à son invention un scaphandre
autonome qui permet de respirer sous
l'eau il a découvert un nouveau monde a
désormais ce monde ils veulent explorer
et pour ça il est prêt à tout sacrifier
la réalisation tendu la beauté des
images le montage rythmé et la bande son
envoûtante accompagne des acteurs bleu
franc qu'il s'agisse aussi bien de
pierre niney lou dray au tout
impressionnante épouse du commandant
quant à lambert wilson il compose un
cousteau à la fois époustouflant
séduisant cassant et blessés les
spectateurs découvriront deux sublimes
prises de vues sous-marines et seront
transportés dans un magnifique voyage à
travers le globe
étonnant et son que le film de jérôme
salle nous fait découvrir des aspects
méconnus de la personnalité du
commandant cousteau le commandant
cousteau et son équipage se lie d'amitié
avec des animaux sauvages mais c'est
super c'est génial bravo
ma
je ne sens et sur la fragile la tête
sous l'eau à l'immensité pureté
l'odyssée est à découvrir cette semaine
à l'espace philippe noiret